Good morning John. Last night, as we must
do in this day and age, I was Googling. I
don't even remember what I was searching for
but as you (I'm sure) know, Google nowadays
actually attempts to guess what you want to
know before you finish telling it what you
want to know. Because apparently we're so
lazy that we'd rather not move our fingers
any more than necessary. It's a clever little
trick and I imagine that it works basically
by figuring out what other people have searched
for that start with the same letters as what
you are searching for. Which is I guess, convenient-ish.
But more than the value is convenient, I think
the real value is it's ability to uh, help
us peer into the soul of mankind.
So let's say we start out with “is”. Lots
of Google queries must begin with the letters
“I S” and then space. And here we have
“is Facebook down?” which is probably
something people search a lot when Facebook
goes down. But the second most common question
starting with “is” asked to Google is
“is lady gaga a man?”. I'll just go ahead
and answer that one for everyone. No. No,
Lady Gaga is not a man.
And then we have the beginning of a trend
that we will see a lot in Google auto-complete,
“Is Daniel Tosh gay?", "Is Justin Bieber
gay?", Is Nate Berkus gay?” I don't even
know who Nate Berkus is!
But to peer deeper into our nation's psyche,
you can type “Is my” and find out what
people are curious about concerning their
possessions. Including, “Is my husband gay?",
"Is my boyfriend gay?", "Is my mac 64 bit”
which is actually a legitimate normal Google
question why aren't they all like that. “Is
my license suspended?” - which is a question
you should really know the answer to and “Is
my house haunted?”. Which... I am amazed.
I, I am, I am just amazed. And then go deeper,
just type a random letter, “is my d-", "Is
my dog pregnant?", "Is my dog sick?", "Is
my dog dying?", "Is my dog gay?” Yes, your
dog is– yeah actually your dog is probably
bisexu– actually your dog is probably omni-sexual.
Your dog has probably had sex with pillows,
your dog is probably ejaculating on the arm
of a couch right now. Wow, our hangups. We
have them.
And then I had a bit of inspiration, and I
had to go ahead and type in, “Is John Green-”
and John, I know you want to know what the
world wants to know about you. “Is John
Green married?”. Yes. “Is John Green gay?".
Is John Green gay? Why does everybody want
to know if everybody's gay?
Let me just go ahead and answer all of these
questions for you. We have yes, no, yes, yes,
no. John Green is not dead. So of course now
that I know what people want to know about
you, I had to figure out what people want
to know about me. And... Piece of a rooster
fard knock a mother of poo. No one cares about
what Hank Green is. So let me ask you guys
a favor, could you go uh, Google “Is Hank
Green awesome?”. Maybe if enough people
do it, it will auto-complete. I find this
exploration fascinating, particularly our
obsession with the sexual orientation of other
people. And I am looking forward to delving
deeper into our nations psyche using the tool
of Google Auto-complete.
And of course finally, I had to ask Google
what people are asking about Google. One letter
into it we're already asking if Google is
making us stupid, but we're also asking “Is
god real?” and “Is gonorrhea curable?”.
But go ahead and type in “is Google ga-”
and you will find out that fewer people are
asking if Google is gaining a monopoly on
the world’s information, than are asking
whether Google is gay. John, Google is a genderless
website that hopefully, has never had a thought.
Much less a feeling of romantic longing. And
thus we can all assume that Google... is not
gay.
John, I will see you on Monday.
Some various news, I just did a collab for
you with HorribleFiction and you can click
to watch it here. The winners for the Project
For Awesome Raffle have been announced and
you have been contacted if you won. If you
haven't been contacted, you win at giving
money to charity. Thank you. I hope you all
have a very, very, very, very, very, very,
very, very, very Happy New Year.